bonjour antoine que s'est-il passé sur
ce territoire de cette république de
donetsk précisément
oui magali et bien vous l'avez dit la
situation est toujours aussi critique le
long de cette ligne de contact sont
d'ailleurs les mots employés par le
porte-parole de la milice autoproclamé
de donetsk hier en fin d'après midi
sachant que dans la nuit les
bombardements continus et toujours dans
les mêmes zones dans dans les quartiers
les mêmes quartiers de donetsk est un
petit peu plus loin le long de cette
ligne de contact on peut notamment on
peut notamment nommé la ville de gorzow
cas ou encore lougansk il ya également
eu une explosion dans le centre de john
yates que cette nuit vers 1h du matin au
niveau à proximité immédiate des locaux
de la première chaîne de télévision de
cette république populaire de données
est alors la dir poutine s'est exprimé
vous l'avez évoqué il a fait savoir que
la russie à l'heure actuelle n'avait pas
vocation à envoyer de troupes a déployé
de troupes dans le territoire du dombass
ici sur le terrain la mobilisation
générale mais aussi les évacuations
continue et signe de l'incertitude que
malgré tout règne dans la population les
gérants continuent à faire le cul au
distributeur de billets pour retirer une
partie de leurs économies même s'il n'y
a pas de pénurie ces mêmes distributeurs
continuent à être régulièrement alimenté
en argent mais signe malgré tout que
cette reconnaissance suscite un immense
espoir auprès de la population il se
murmure que cette date du 22 février
pourrait devenir jours de fête dans le
donbass en tant que jour de leur
reconnaissance
merci beaucoup antoine pour toutes ces
précisions antoine cléroux en direct de
donetsk